un tgv est médicalisé une première en
europe
oh
en
[Musique]
je remercie aussi l'ensemble des
territoires qui ont accepté de prendre
en charge des malades graves de
réanimation dans des hôpitaux
c'est les patients qui sont donc koffi
19 positifs qui ont eu un syndrome de
détresse respiratoire aiguë modérée à
sévère et qui sont donc évacué pour la
poursuite de leur prise en charge
il correspond typiquement à la
physionomie qu'on en a maintenant en
france et patient quand même jeunes en
moyenne ils ont autour de 60 ans voire
un peu moins 100 de très très grosses
comorbidités dans d'autres maladies
ce qu'ils aient retrouvé souffrances et
des maladies cardiovasculaires
on a besoin de libérer des places pour
en libère une place ça donne une place
pour un nouveau patient est donc sauvé
une vie pour pas qu'ils aient un
embouteillage entre guillemets sur les
ressources hospitalières
[Musique]
on court derrière
pourquoi es tu
[Musique]
et vous
non
[Musique]